it's time for screen junkies movie
fights what up y'all it's another
edition of movie fights as always yeah
and as always if you are watching in the
comfort of your home own home pants
optional all right let's meet our
fighters for the day first off you don't
miss the pit boss he's been here there
schmoes no screen junkies and today he's
a birthday boy happy to be here by 42nd
birthday so we're doing we're doing the
tile we're doing the bathrobe where ours
are Denton it up here so glad to be here
with you guys not happy that dance here
it's gonna be fun yes yes Dan the
specter of Dan looms over moving rights
but Ken thank you for spending your
birthday with us and thank you for
keeping a cash keep back yeah she just
won last month's movie fights at
Anaheim's WonderCon you could find her
all over the internet she's a phenomenon
Erica a she what up I don't thanks so
much for having me it's my first movie
fight oh heck yeah well you're young
you're first like at WonderCon it was
kind of chaos reigned supreme so of
course I do well there but well see how
I do in the actual range yes let's see
if you can hone that chaos and use it to
defeat your powerful foes speaking of
powerful foes you uh you know I'm from
honest trailers screen junkies all over
the place a the longest-reigning movie
fights champion in history your
reputation precedes you sir Dan Merle
is my first movie fight - yeah that's my
birthday
lies all eyes I just fact check those
things on top of thing yes Dan always
good to have you here yes Wow
three powerful competitors and we have
some powerful folks checking facts and
speaking as the voice of the people
first off in the fact-checking chair
welcome to the party lawn Harris oh
thanks for having me what a great party
not Dan's birthday thank you totally yes
thank you for checking that fact that I
also just checked in my head well yeah I
am adding my confirmation on I
appreciate you you know else I
appreciate oh she is the conduit of the
people and Justin an angel from heaven
above please welcome Daniel rapper you
know how this works
we do have a voting system for y'all
there as a poll it is on the youtube if
you were looking for instructions on how
that works
pop down to that description it will
have everything you need and so in the
case of any kind of like a tie or
whatever is that's when we turn to you
all and I will also be reading all of
your dank memes yes sender sick meme
sender dank memes oh I said you see I
know you're a huge Corgi enthusiast the
Queen's last Corgi
just killed Harambee or something first
of all that person who loves to Smurfs
the Smurfs needs to get over it because
the source have jumped the shark okay
never call me Gargamel okay so again let
me explain it for you if your Andrey
familiarize you with our format we have
three regular round questions and then
we have four speed round questions and
if we if we're tied one-one one after
the three rounds we got tie breakers if
so and each round is judged by myself
and lon and then your YouTube vote and
yeah I think that's about it LAN
anything anything I missed there buddy I
think you hit all of it except if
another adorable thing is drop dead want
to let us know that will do I'll look
for some way to announce the death of
something beautiful a new Benjy
tick-tock all right we got three
fighters we got seven rounds oh man
exciting times jte dropped that sickest
package
[Music]
[Applause]
JT word on the street is he is the best
package in the biz alright let's jump
into round number one anybody heard the
offenders and Finch Moore's movies
opening up summer movie season is
starting off what will be the best movie
of the summer what will be the best
movie and we're gonna start off with the
birthday boy can naps on all right I'm
gonna come out of the box swingin Wes
Wiggin with a baseball bat no a shark
the Meg starring Jason Statham I think
he's in the movie I don't know I just
saw the trailer a lot of things were
happening I was excited look at that a
Megalodon you've heard of a Megalodon
how you don't need to that surfer didn't
and that surfers dead now this is the
epitome of the summer movie season this
is silliness
this is seriousness this is a little bit
of fear do you like going into bathtubs
and other kind of general bodies of
water I don't and this movie's gonna
drive that point home and I'm gonna have
a lot of fun doing it I love adventures
you guys know I love Star Wars there's a
lot of great movies coming out this
summer but the summer season the one
that's gonna be the most talked about
remember that sharknado thing well this
is a better version of it it's the Meg
with Jason Statham
all right opening salvos and one
interesting thing I just took out of
that you don't like bathtubs you like
bodies of water like sitting in dirty
soup water deejays good point Erica a
she
so Incredibles 2 we have been waiting
over a decade for this film the first
one was an incredible classic pardon the
pun and this one it seems from all of
the trailers that it really has updated
to the feeling of now it's it's still
about family it's still and but it's got
Helen and Bob Parr are examining their
roles like their spouse roles and like
what it means to you know how have
gender roles and be a family in the
society and balance career and family
and the kids are growing up they let the
writing and the kids and everybody grow
along with the story Pixar is on the top
of their game right now Coco was
absolutely incredible in terms of
storytelling and Pixar has a really
great track record with sequels by
especially sequels that come out a lot
later than the originals if you look at
the Toy Story franchise its I'm really
looking forward to this this one is
gonna be an absolute classic a lot of
summer blockbusters you know don't
really smooth stand the test of time but
I feel that Incredibles definitely will
alright opening salvo from Erika Dan
Moreau what's your pick people think
summer movie they think spectacle I
looked at the different ones I was
almost going like a Mission Impossible
that looks cool but then I saw the movie
that I'm actually looking forward to the
most just on a artistic level and that
is Sicario day of the Soldado used to be
called Sicario to Soldado but they just
changed the name I love the first
Sicario movie I thought it was great it
was a movie that was nominated for
multiple Academy Awards multiple BAFTAs
all means like 150 different nominations
from so many different critics groups
and award shows I love vanilla toys del
Toro's character in that movie I thought
he was such a great complex interesting
character I love that they are
continuing this storyline with him
because you know as great as the kind of
procedural police government agent story
was in the first one he was the one that
I came out of that like what happened to
that guy he kind of he gets away and and
you don't know what's gonna happen to
him and I love that they're gonna keep
taking this border war thing and
escalate that story I love the kind of
murkiness of the ethics and the politics
and the morality in these movies there's
a lot of movies that will grant you
they're gonna have more spectacle than
Sicario but I think when we look back
much like when Saving Private Ryan was a
summer movie back in 1998 there is a
precedent for great great movies to come
out during the summer and I think that
Sicario day of the Soldado is going to
be that moving this year and 2018 all
right Wow three very different movies go
ahead and slug it out y'all so I I would
have agreed with you except that
Villeneuve and Emily Blunt are not in
this one apparently with emily Blunt's
characters they she felt that her arc
was over and but they've kind of
replaced the character of like the
audience surrogate with just another
woman and Villeneuve he his directorial
style brought so much to it and
the director that they've replaced him
with is going to they say try and
emulate that feeling so I don't know how
that's gonna turn out if they'd given it
a different feeling I I would have been
a lot more excited about I agree with
Erica on this Dan I think what you which
you got here is the runaway bride to the
pretty woman of Sicario here you got a
different team you've got a lot of some
of the similar faces and spectacle how
about terrifying cancel your our trip to
Cabo honey this movie just made me
afraid and I'm gonna lock myself endorse
it is ethics politics morality grab some
popcorn that's not a summer blockbuster
this might be the best movie in terms of
of film cinephile sit down and join it
but this is the summer baby I want to
chase a shark well thank you for just
admitting that I might have the best
movie the summer because that's what
this argument is about ken it's about
what the best movie of the summer is
gonna be sure I appreciate that
unfortunately I think that the make
looks like it looks like it might be fun
the tone seems a little all over the
place they had too many like one-liners
of that with a one goofy character going
like well you know some sort of Jaws
like reference and so I mean I don't
know if it's gonna be good need to be
good for the popular summer camp yeah I
never once watched jaws and said I
wonder what this movie would be like if
the guy who directed a national treasure
- there they have their splitting of
their attention way too far there was
like a crack in and also like a hood
officials and shadowy rooms talking
about go ahead and do what you have to
do to win this war on drugs go ahead and
do all this thing's already want to
watch a hammerhead fight a crack and
what Jason Statham does I don't have to
pay $17 a chutes in this talking about
Shark Week people love Shark Week
populace you're talking about art specta
Sicario is art that art belongs in the
winter I am perfect
matchup of the two it's going to be
spectacle and fun and like heartwarming
and good for the family and the populace
but also it is going to be an Oscar
contender we know that okay what's your
favorite movie my favorite movie of all
time yes it's clearly will oh no mad
Morrigan it's Indiana solo in the
Fellowship of the ewoks you know this
damn what's the point what are you
trying to turn the doors open in the
some age you'd come out any time of the
year can it doesn't have to be in the
winter and see and there like I said
there have been plenty of great movies
they all come out in the summer it
doesn't just have to be a winter summer
thing I'm not fighting against you I've
actually tried to brace for you for
impact when you're disappointed this
summer when a big shark chasing around a
weird cast of characters wins the day
when people like did you go see
Incredibles do and now you know I
wouldn't saw the shark movie again cuz
it was so crazy let's turn our attention
to the Incredibles because first
Incredibles is a great movie Erica
you've made a great choice here this is
a superhero movie that was before its
time
14 years ago my friends kids have
grandchildren now that haven't seen the
first movie 14 years is an eon 4 to try
to get kids to go back plus it's muddled
they're gonna go in there and be like is
this the one with Iron Man I'm not I
don't know now it's gonna be lost in the
shuffle I think that you are severely
under estimating the intelligence of
children also I you made the point that
superhero films are huge now it has even
more to say than it did 14 years ago but
I turn my attention Incredibles 2 also
first of all a Pixar shocked record was
stellar lately not so much and you talk
about sequels like you know Toy Story 2
here right that was a great sequel of
Toy Story but they've also made cards
too and cars lines as well I saw planes
three at a gas station like on the gas
station honest here I mean cars the
front as the franchise was always kind
of set to fund films like The
Incredibles or up or the the more risky
films that they do I mean this is risky
this is risky no that's the thing car
like well it's more it's more steps to
it it's got more debt than something
like cars were they're like Oh
gonna sell merchandise what's the other
thing that you mentioned about the like
oh there expand there it's the marriage
to finding the roles in the marriage but
they did that already did it in the
first move that's what the first movie
was about the first was about exploring
their marriage and their roles in the
family and from what I see in this one
it looks like kind of the same thing
yeah except that the roles are reversed
and that's what's actually interesting
to me because we saw you know the
classic story of you know the wife the
housewife at home you know some of the
1950s and she's struggling with that and
now we get to deal with the reverse of
that and I think that we don't get to
see that often enough I like men having
to examine what it means to be a man in
today's world and like with their wife
is going off and ken you were about to
speak make this your final thoughts and
we'll go around here some final I love
what you're saying about Incredibles -
who doesn't want to see Craig Dean else
and find his place in the world but the
problem is this is 14 years coming not
too late but it's 14 years there's gonna
be a lot of pressure a lot of people
that's gonna make people have the
ability to be easily disappointed from
this sicarios just gonna terrify them
not saying it's not gonna be a great
movie but I going to sit there and be
like you know what I'd like to see just
simply a large shark kicking ass and one
man and a team of casting weird cast of
characters taking it down that's a
summer blockbuster movie
Erica final thoughts Incredibles - I
haven't really heard any good arguments
against it because I mean we we both we
all know that like even at its very
worst Pixar makes spectacular films and
it's it's gonna be timeless I thank you
I disagree is that even it's very worst
picture makes utterly forgettable films
the good dinosaur was a completely
forgettable film they have not had the
same track record of late Brad Bird the
last movie we saw him write and direct
was Tomorrowland which was not a great
movie I think that it's a little spotty
er than it has been in the past I think
that before I when I think of the meg I
think of snakes on a plane it's a thing
that sounds like a good idea but then
you're in the movie you're watching the
movie and you're like oh my god this was
a much better idea than it is an actual
movie I think with Sicario Davis salado
yes you don't have DNA Villeneuve but
you have Taylor Sheridan who was coming
back to write the script he's wrote the
first Accardo he's written hell or high
water he's actually Wind River he's
actually written nothing but great
movies you have James Brolin and I'm
sorry Josh Brolin and Benicio del Toro
coming back I think you have a
compelling story and again this isn't
best summer blockbuster this isn't best
this is what is the best movie of the
summer gonna be when you look at the
components when you look at the track
records when you look at just the raw
materials for each of these movies I
think at the end of the day it's gonna
be Sicario BAM okay Wow nicely done
nicely fought well there were just
takedowns and blows and points scored
throughout that round and and there were
accidental points scored for the other
team I mean Erica when you when you said
it's a Kraken versus a hammerhead I'm
like where do I sign Wow get me in line
for that but then I think you both took
Ken down effectively with just that
argument that it does look like sci-fi
fair and then I think Dan doubled down
on that with the whole snakes on the
plane comparison Dan I really man your
closing argument they're listing the the
screenwriting credits of the
screenwriter of Sicario that it's an
impressive slate okay comes down Dan and
Erica for me Erica they there were some
interesting takedowns of Incredibles to
potentially and Pixar in as much as
Pixar's track record has not been
perfect but at the end of the day I
think painting Sicario as potentially
losing something
losing Denny Villeneuve who's one of the
great directors of our in recent years
and Emily Blunt I think that is a bigger
take down than anything they leveled
against Erica I don't think we had
something that really put a dent in your
Incredibles 2 argument so because of
that I'm going Erica and Incredibles to
long terms of facts no facts to correct
I did one point out Erica made a very
good point that links up to the facts
about Pixar's had a lot of success at
the box office with sequels finding
Dory's their most profitable film in the
u.s. overall plus twice three three
monsters you and Toy Story 2 so I
thought that was a good point and Dan
made a good point too same from Ryan
open
was a summer movie we didn't come up
during the match but the director of
Soldado was mentioned it's Stefano
sollima he directed the well-received
Italian thrillers Gomorrah and Saburo so
there in terms of the fight itself I'm
with you how I think it really came down
to Eric and Dan I feel like if the
question had been what is like the
ultimate summer movie then I would have
really but in terms of the questions the
best so I really felt like it came down
to this - I thought it was awfully close
between Erika and Dan but I thought
Dan's final argument really put me over
the top where I think he made a strong
case for the people who are
collaborating in this movie and then it
would overall just be the movie that's
gonna be the most memorable in the work
we're gonna remember 5 10 years from now
so I go Dan alright we're locked up at 1
1 Danielle do his favor break this tie
alright well going on to the YouTube
polls oh it's like not even super close
The Incredibles - with 56% Sakura - at
24% and the Meg at 19% 19% of right
which is 19% of nothing and were there
any cool suggestions dank memes or other
choices for top movie picks well
everyone was like infinity war we had
some people who were very upset that
Deadpool 2 didn't get referenced and
everyone is so into that Riddler dress
right nice great time to be a geeky gal
and same as always being a geeky guy
alright that's fine whatever man so many
sweet mashup t-shirts I love
use some more gentleman's fashion man we
live in a day and age Orion get Game of
Thrones beer koozies okay question
number two Super Troopers part deux it's
not called that Super Troopers two it
opens this weekend which classic comedy
most deserves a sequel which classic
comedy most deserves a sequel and we're
gonna start off with player number two
Erika Ishii I really seriously want a
Galaxy Quest sequel now before you you
talk about like you know the first one
was so perfect the first one was an
amazing sort of gentle ribbing of and
celebration of Star Trek and fandom and
the second one but all fandom and Star
Trek have changed significantly since
Galaxy Quest first came out so I mean
III pitch to you now the idea of the
cast coming back you know there's been a
reboot of the original show in which
like these sexy new young actors have
been cast how do they deal with that how
do they deal with instead of being
husbands being like like the hot thing
at a hot panel at comic-con how do they
deal with Alan Rickman's death that's
the thing is that like Leonard Nimoy and
other Star Trek characters have passed
away since Galaxy Quest and so how do
they deal with like the recasting and
and just how the fandom reacts to that I
think that it is incredibly relevant now
because all of us I mean just it means
something different you know Star Trek
and and fandom and cons are all
different now and there's so much to be
explored and gently teased about that so
I say Galaxy Quest is due for a sequel
right on thank you Erica Dan Merle my
pick is one of my personal favorite
comedies of the 21st century Team
America world police I love this movie
and I think what gets lost is a lot of
people laugh at the puppet part of it
which is hilarious but my favorite thing
about it was that Team America world
police is such a kind of funhouse mirror
snapshot of culture American culture at
that time both how we see ourselves
and how other people see us it was at
the height of the super humongously
patriotic early part of the 21st century
and the idea of like America the world's
policemen and like you know the force
that's going out but also like going to
like all these countries and blowing
stuff up in like the Eiffel Tower at the
beginning it was such a kind of like
twisted other side of the mirror look at
both America and the end the world and I
think that you can do it again but my
pitch for this would be that this would
be called team world America police and
it is again a kind of a funhouse mirror
look today at how America is seen in the
world which is you know now a lot of
people are like that early 21st century
thing is kind of worn off and it's kind
of one of the things like what is the
matter are they you know how are we
seeing abroad and and this idea of like
the other world inside this universe
that America Team America has reached so
much chaos that now every other country
has their own Team America to fight to
face Team America so now you have a
global for its fighting Team America I
think that it's a way that they get the
same you get parking stone back it's a
way to kind of look at the last 15 years
see what's happened and be able to laugh
not just it ourselves but at the world
because that's what Team America let you
do particularly you know the with North
Korea was that was at that time and
still a very serious situation and it
still is and what that movie did was
make everything ridiculous and when
everything is ridiculous
you have room to kind of parity at
parity the Hollywood it parity the u.s.
at parity to other countries and that's
I think what we need to do right now
I think we'd so so badly need a great
satire right now so that we can look at
the ridiculousness of so many aspects of
the world that we live in right now and
be able to laugh at it and I think that
this would open up a venue in a way to
do that and to do that in a way that
people will accept that you know the the
the first scene America it made fun of
the people on the right and it made fun
of the people on the left it made fun of
Alec Baldwin and it made fun of Michael
Moore and it made fun of there are no
sacred cows and I think that's what we
need right now so team world America
police thank you Dan kidnaps up we're
gonna go with the big lebowski still
rolling that's right this is a classic
cult comedy as are the other two choices
here this is a great round great
selections by my fellow fighters here
but this is a comedy that people have
been waiting to see what happens to
these characters and through that you're
gonna be able to make comments on
society and current times and all that
kind of stuff but beyond all that you're
gonna have a story here you have the
potential to move these characters
forward and not just check in and see
what's happened to them you're gonna
have a chance to live I'd spend a couple
hours with these great characters that
so many people fell in love with that an
entire convention was started around the
first movie this has been a long time
coming and I want the Khan brothers to
sit on down with the dude and tell us
the continuing Adventures of The Big
Lebowski
all right fighters clash I think when
you talk about The Big Lebowski in
particular it's like you said still
rolling like that's the whole appeal of
those characters if the question is and
I think that's the question you should
always ask in any sequel what are these
characters doing now the answer is gonna
be they're doing the exact same thing
that's the bow ski has been doing the
same thing for two years it's like if
you try to make him be different than
what's the point and if you try to have
him do the same thing then it's just a
retread Plus Donny's gone
Donny was such a hugely funny character
in the first movie the actual Big
Lebowski unfortunately has passed away
Philip Seymour Hoffman unfortunately is
passed away I think there's so many key
elements of that first movie that are
gone that you can't get back oh yeah
also I don't think it would add anything
to the story and to do it I mean that
was it was it was just perfect as it was
you know it maybe if you had some other
like completely separate story but then
it wouldn't be the big lebowski the dude
stays the same you're right the ditch
days to say plus the worlds when it
would be around him is always gonna
change and there's circumstances again
he's gonna stumble and find himself in
two with Walter Sobchak that's going to
make another story it's not gonna be
something just relying on a another film
the war version over there and yeah you
know you're talking about key elements
no longer there but with this you could
tell me you can't have like a force
ghost Donnie dan this is what we've got
to just bring
Kenny Rogers and the new addition song
sequencing you got you got a donnie
giving them advice during the entire
moving it's gonna make sense cuz the
dudes probably just so stoned so it's
it's yes you're right I understand what
you're saying about the characters but
what did the characters do in the first
movie all this stuff happened to him and
add to how they survive the
circumstances that smacked them up in
the face that story I'd want to tell
your two movies I think the one the
biggest issue is a change in tone to two
very perfect movies and I don't know I
don't know if they'd be received as well
as it were today if you would try to do
you say laughing ourselves I wish we
could laugh at ourselves dead thing
about Trey Parker and Matt Stone and I
am a fan of them they need to pick a
side
we live in the time right now where you
can't just be like everything's funny
some things are just not funny anymore
like there are some sides that are
correct nowadays like you were on the
internet you know that like how how it's
not well you can't like sit up on your
ivory tower and just pretend that
everybody can be rigged like all the
same because it's not it's not that way
anymore
and I I don't think that we can make
that film anymore like if some other
country wanted to make this film and
poke fun at us that'd be fine I guess I
don't know I don't know that we could do
that anymore but that's kind of their
whole philosophy is that if if nothing
is off-limits then that frees you up
it's this idea of Sacher it's satirizing
that exact mindset of like there are
some things you just can't talk about
that that's what you can't talk about
it's just that like I think that by you
know staying in the middle and
pretending that there isn't a right side
and a wrong side there being safe like I
I'd say that if you did a team America
that you can't do everybody like you you
you have to pick a side I I disagree
that I disagree that fundamentally and I
think that's why Team America the first
movie worked was because it didn't take
the side of like it took the site of
America and a very over-the-top
satirical way and again it's like North
Korea's America's enemy like yeah that's
true but at the same time it treated
kind of had a twisted look at that it's
like in a weird way they're the
protagonist it's not it's not picking a
side it's just choosing to
her eyes both sides differently and I
think there's absolutely a way that you
can and again I just think would be a
minefield of humor I'm coming down
America here's one of my favorite movie
but I just don't know if the world is
interested in puppets scheisse videos at
this point and and just it's a different
it's a different world out there where I
don't know if we'd be received do I want
to see it yeah but I just think it's a
minefield of humor that's dangerous I'm
at sternness that they do not want to
work with puppets anymore like it was
impossible to get the puppets to do
anything they said and so they're
they're just done with puppets but as
for Galaxy Quest you know it would very
much take the same tone and I think like
if you go back and look at it it's like
so much of the comedy from that air is
like oh look at these nerds like look
how dumb they are but like Galaxy Quest
celebrated fandom like in the end the
kids that are fans of things like they
got to be the heroes at the end of the
day and and I really love that and I
think that we all want to see that we
all need to see that right now but
minded thing is like again it's the same
things like what what does it going to
add to the first one and it is such a
huge I mean
for me without Alan Rickman that that
whole that's the question that you have
to ask like and a lot of people say like
well without like Leonard anymore like
why they never made they never ever
attempted to do an original cast picture
without Spock except for the search for
Spock which is literally about finding
him and bringing him back to life is
that you have to explore what that means
within that world to be missing somebody
who's so pivotal to like this cast that
everybody loves and and like what what
it adds to it is a look at fandom this
in this day and age right now which is
completely different because and that in
in the old one it was like the idea that
these TV stars are has bins and like you
know the the fandom is like there's
still like really geeks that live at
their parents homes and stuff
but now like geeks are like have
disposable income you know they're hot
now go ahead and fold this into your
closing argument we're gonna hear final
thoughts Galaxy Quest is veer was very
much ahead of its time and that it was
an examination
and celebration of fandom I think that
is something that we could do with again
we could examine what fandom of Star
Trek and or you know the Galaxy Quest
means to people right now it's very
relevant to us as geeks thanks Erica
damn I agree Galaxy Quest is very
relevant to us as geeks but I don't see
what else needs to be said I think it's
a very pure message about fandom I don't
really know why you would want to update
cuz it is about how fans of something
can be their biggest cheerleaders and
the importance of the purity of that and
I really don't know what else you can
add to that message because it's already
such a great and positive message and I
think that any side of the fandom you
can look at right now is kind of the
negative side which I don't there's just
too many things with Galaxy Quest and
I'm like I you know I love that first
movie so much and it was so pure that I
almost don't want to touch it because I
think there's so many other things like
without Alan Rickman and the the
potential negative sides phantom that
you haven't addressed yet that it just
seems like it has the potential to be
kind of a downer and again with Big
Lebowski I think the great thing about
those guys was that they are completely
normal dudes who get caught up in this
weird situation and for it to happen to
them again to me seems a little
contrived I'm perfectly happy with my
mental image of the dudes staying in the
same apartment still bowling with John
Goodman
Walter every week and you know I don't
know what it's gonna add to the mythos
of The Big Lebowski to see them do all
of that again and I think Team America
again has an opportunity to satirize the
u.s. satirize the world in a way that
can be cathartic to some people and
you're right people do kind of tiptoe
around things and I think that they've
established a universe where you can
open yourself up to to laugh a little
bit about it because that's what
comedies role is particularly in on
trouble in troubled times which is when
the first movie was made there were very
troubled times I think you can still
laugh and I think that it's actually
useful I think satire is useful in
situations like that
thank you Dan Ken all right what we're
talking about here is laughing at
ourselves all these three movies ask us
to laugh at ourselves in a different way
and I think now that would be more
difficult for world police to accomplish
and I think it'd be actually different
for Galaxy Quest to come so I was
nerd who got beat up on the playgrounds
in the 80s that name that word meant a
lot to me then a lot different than that
it does now so the Galaxy Quest atone
would change because now geek is big
business so do we want to see Tim Allen
go through that kind of stuff again with
all due respect to Billy the world's
biggest Tim Allen fan there in the booth
I don't know there I think the tone has
changed for both these movies where the
Big Lebowski you could accomplish this
needed satire that Dan's talking about
but you do in a way that's not going to
start wars to the theaters flame wars on
Twitter it's just going to be two guys
Bowl and having fun and some craziness
going on between them and the story all
right Wow there we go three great
comedies which is the greatest potential
sequel nicely fought round of applause
from Joe star long give us the facts Wow
not a lot we'll only one fact to check
it's Kenny Rogers and the first edition
I say
it's perfectly clean around as far as I
could tell I these were three great
movies I love all three of these movies
and I really liked all three of these
pitches
I thought the team world America police
pitch was amazing at that point in the
fight I was like Dan's got this and that
was a pretty pitch but I have to say
Erica kind of came from behind she had a
good response to everything everyone
threw at her I really liked her response
to the Rickman issue that like yeah the
movie would be about how Galaxy Quest
keeps going without that character I
just thought she was wrong I thought
Kendall was was really strong out the
gate too but kind of lost me on Donny
the force ghost
I think that's e'terica so that's a one
vote for Erica yeah Ken I I love Big
Lebowski and I would watch I would watch
another one but as far as a pitch goes I
didn't hear as much from you and Donny
the force ghost is weird dan I loved
your I loved your argument but then it
became divisive right here at the table
and I'm not sure or if that film would
be too mired in politics everything that
we threw at Erica I feel like she folded
into her argument she made it a part of
it and like the sexy young cast being
rebooted in a new Galaxy Quest and how
they reacted to it I thought Erika's was
the most airtight and she gets my vote
as well so Erika takes this point
Danielle what did the YouTube pull up to
say alright so going to be YouTube poll
and once again if y'all are just joining
us we do have a YouTube pull up where
you do have to get you do get your voice
heard if you need a new structures that
I do that go down to the description for
this one I'm not breaking any ties so
this is just letting you hit everyone
know what y'all think and far and away
Team America world police 50% Galaxy
Quest 33% and the big lebowski at 11% we
had a lot of people who would be
interested in a UHF sequel should be
yeah which would be super interesting a
lot of people mentioned and
Undercover Brother to which I can be
super down with and then Joel at chaos
magician 77 says the room sequel when
Johnny gets raised back from the dead
and is out for revenge I mean it's hot
right now there was any time to make a
room sequel it would be right now
Tommy wheeze Oh give me a call okay you
know forget Tommy was oh do not go yeah
let's go to question number two
labyrinth is going to be adapted as a
stage musical what movie would make the
best stage musical and Dan we're gonna
start with you this is where there must
have been something in the water this
week because I swear I didn't intend to
do this but I was sitting down I
considered both of these questions on
their own terms and yet I ended up
almost exactly where I was with the last
question because I sat down and thought
what would I be what would I pay out my
$400 whatever now it costs to go see a
musical and it was South Park
bigger Longer & uncut the stage version
of the 1999 movie which is itself
already a musical this is not
unprecedented some of the most
successful Broadway musicals of all time
started out as movie musicals I think
you do what the musical version of the
producers did which was you go back to
the source you tweak some of the stuff
that might seem a little dated you
update it a little bit but the bones are
there for such an amazing stage musical
number one Trey Parker and Matt says
don't know how to do this they did it
with the Book of Mormon that moved that
musical 1 9 Tony's it's still running on
Broadway Plus whoever you cast is Satan
I promise you
guaranteed Tony there's no way that's
not win a Tony you're gonna get a great
name up there is one of the best ballets
ever written if it was in a Disney movie
it wouldn't want an Oscar but they
nominated blame Canada instead which is
like the fourth best song in that
musical I think it's a hilarious musical
I think it's a great one I think it
would look great staged and again I love
the you know in the kind of stolid old
ways of Broadway I love the musical that
goes that comes in that's a reverent
that shakes it up that makes them
I think that South Park would make an
incredible Broadway musical all right
thank you Dan can nap suck alright I am
out of that I have a life philosophy
that other forms of entertainment have
been created since 1862 so I don't think
we need stage musicals at all dan said
exactly what I'm thinking here the old
ways of Broadway and I know that's
changed that's a good thing we got a lot
of people hip to what's going on
Broadway they want to go get tickets
they want to see it I get it I get it I
get it but you know what Broadway still
about expensive tickets and old money so
we are going with a classic we're gonna
take that that romantic comedy the one
that set it all up when Harry Met Sally
it had to be you look at the numbers
we've got here do you want to hear the
orgasm song I know you do you're gonna
have what she's having
When Harry Met Sally all right orgasm
song Erika Ishii Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world so Edgar Wright every single one
of his films is already so close to a
musical in the way that it's staged in
the choreography the rhythmic nature of
you know the numbers like the way things
are done like if you saw a baby driver
or any of the Cornetto trilogy or Scott
Pilgrim even it's like music is folded
and in such a beautiful way I've been
praying for him to collaborate with
lin-manuel Miranda on something I'm so
there were already part way there
Scott's a guitarist you know his attacks
are through or with the guitar so he
gets like all these rock ballad numbers
on each one of the evil exes gets a gets
an amazing villain song a duet for the
twins and his ex-girlfriend is a rock
star so she gets a [ __ ] diva number
that's gonna be a showstopper and it's
it's big it's bombastic it's colorful it
lends itself perfectly you know because
it's it's just so dramatic
also I have a pitch for you of who is
going to write this musical Pasic and
paul who just did dear Evan Hanson which
is a coming-of-age story that was
nominated for nine Tony
it's about a young man who's coming of
age just like Scott Pilgrim they also
did the greatest showmen which is poppy
and catchy and has a lot of the feeling
that I would want for this musical and
it is about essentially being a less
crappy person which is exactly what
Scott Pilgrim is about with him and
Ramona I just I honestly like was
looking into this and I and I was like
starting to think of the numbers as
they're happening as there's music that
weaves itself throughout them both the
original source material of the material
in the manga or comic and in Edgar
Wright's film anyway so Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world
the musical please all right you throw
down jr. concert for old money that
still makes Broadway jukebox musicals
right now are not doing as hot as the
original things you know so like having
like the Green Day musical didn't do so
well and just so every day this is no
Dookie this is Harry Connick jr. Frank
Sinatra this is a classic love story
play now look you could see you can
envision this about Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world great choice is it gonna be as
underwhelming at the box office at the
place it is the movie no one we're
nowhere to gather around that after the
big nobody cuz nobody knew who Edgar
Wright was and it wasn't marketed
correctly but it has a huge cult
following afterwards and I I think that
like yeah now that people know what it
is that yeah people will be excited
about it and it's not even so much about
the fact that it is like Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world as that this story itself
and all the characters and everything
lend itself to a good musical because at
the end of the day that's what it needs
to be about it's not about name
recognition for the movies or anything
because that is not a guarantee of
quality as a musical South Park is so
incredibly dated like that I love the
South Park movie I still have
then one of my favorite soundtracks but
it is like just the whole thing is so
incredibly dated and like vaguely like
homophobic and I can't see you
redoing enough of it to make it good and
also I want the boys to do another good
musical like like Book of Mormon did
really well they have ideas in their
head and they can still use that classic
structure of the musical theater to do
something new and innovative they don't
need to bring South Park to Broadway I
think they do very much and I agree
there are elements of the musical that
are dated that's why you update it for
the stage that happens ever even when
you revive an old musical they they
revise and update things to bring it
into a more modern the scene and like
there was again you go to the producers
they had a whole hippie dippie 60s guy
that was like a man in the movie that
didn't work they wrote that out of the
musical they wrote in new characters
they modernized it they adapted it it
was a better version he's the primary
antagonist in the film actually gonna
work out you can have actors with
something like weird face some of the
magic right there it's in the
characterization of music it's in the
lyrics you don't lose anything you cast
smart you rewrite you modernize it you
make it great and you tell me that you
wouldn't pay $300 to see a chorus line
of classically trained actors line up
and sing uncle [ __ ] like I turn made a
wrong turn I mean go back to Harlem what
am i doing I'm gonna need the actors who
play the kids to have voices that are
high enough you'd like it's really it'll
be adults it won't be kids I know and so
not of a lot of adults have that range
just like from Spain from like it's like
alto tenor like those those kids are
like Sopranos and how are we gonna get
but guys it's literally the biggest
group of classically trained singers in
the Broadway acting you'll find them yes
I know but they just don't have the
range to go up that high and do kid
voices and singing kid voices I think
they will find talented before I would
it's just that I mean you literally
cannot find people that can sing that hi
I think I think that it is a really
entertaining visual movie I don't see
that translate into the stage I think
they tried to do the kind of style over
substance thing with spider-man and I
think you would need that kind of
production value in order to kind of WoW
people in the way that like that movie
is so stunning like that's what has
going for it more than anything is the
visuals the story I actually don't like
I don't like Scott as a character again
unless she revised the ending I don't
really like the ending of the musical
like the story for me is the least
compelling thing about Scott Pilgrim and
I don't think you could put it on at a
big enough scale to outdo the movie to
get people to go see it that wouldn't
also be just like cost prohibitive and a
potential disaster like Spiderman was
you've really got a I mean up everything
about the thing is that the at the end
of the day like that's why I brought up
greatest showman like PT Barnum was a
crappy crappy guy and yet like people
love that musical because like it
repaints him and it's really compelling
and the musical numbers are what sell it
and that is what pacing and Paul do best
they also did lala land which is like we
all hated the characters from La Land we
all hate it like at least everybody in
LA really disliked a lot of the plot of
lala land but like those musical numbers
really sold it and it's like a one-of
ton of awards and it was had a lot of
redeeming qualities because of Pasic and
paul's work but those are two movies and
movies and stage musicals are not the
same thing they just a dear Ivan Hanson
Hanson like that is a compelling story
and that's my problem with Scott Pilgrim
is I don't think it's a compelling story
he's not he's not it's not like Durov
and Hanson where I'm like rooting for
the characters in this thing like I
don't really root for Scott when I watch
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world cuz I don't
think he's a great guy I don't think
there's really a lot of people in that
musical that are great and I think
that's what you mean they still again
like they it goes back to lala land and
greatest showmen of these kind of
unlikable characters that are you know
are kind of redeemed in that you do root
for because we're gonna call it right
there Wow
three potentially money-losing musical
so it is expensive lawn facts not a lot
of facts to check everybody seemed right
on there was a nobody knew who Edgar
Wright was when Scott Pilgrim came out
issue I was sort of like that's right on
the bubble of being a fact versus a
opinion opinion so I'll leave it it is
true that a lot of stage musicals did
start out as movie musicals Newsies Mary
Poppins Gigi Chitty Chitty Bang Bang
gotta love Dan's Harry Connick jr.
concert I wanted to hear more from Ken
about what a Harry Met Sally musical
would be I just I like the concept but I
felt like we didn't really dig into it
beyond like you get a lot of those sort
of classic songs in there so it kind of
came down to Dan versus Erika to me I
was I mean it was it was really close I
thought Erika made a lot of good points
and I liked that she had it felt really
worked out like here's what a lot like
ears would write it here's what a lot of
the songs would be musicals gonna use it
or your love of musicals Everly came
through but ultimately when it came
right down to it I just thought like did
just chipped away at enough of it and
even though I agree with Erika that the
Supper movie feels kind of dated right
now I got to give this round - damn
that's one for Dan you had me at the
beginning I almost called everything off
orgasm song yeah okay but then Erika
thing about jukebox musicals being hit
and miss and the Harry Connick jr. line
was almost a fatal to Erika and Dan for
me and Erika your opening salvo was off
the charts but um
I agree with a lot of what lon said and
Dan when I mean you brought back uncle
[ __ ] which is an amazingly funny song
there is so much funny in that in that
movie and listing some of the roles that
would just be delicious for actors to
play Satan and the track record of Trey
Parker and Matt Stone on Broadway
already that became the more realistic
thing and came at a great takedown in
new Erica saying Scott Pilgrim was not a
hit would it translate would people buy
the tickets so I go down as well Dan
gets the point
and it's - let's hear what the poll had
to say um well if it would load sorry um
but I already know because I've been
I've been monitoring the polls so they
definitely were going real real bad it
was real real real real van um so sorry
it's I'm having difficulties I'll see
what I can thank you but I will look at
some of the some of the memes that we
saw which were pretty good at Joe Baca
defense said Batman versus Superman just
so we can hear an emotional duet called
Martha why did you say that name south
park with 58% Scott Pilgrim with 29% and
when Harry Met Sally with 11% again how
does that keep happening we also had
Tampa Buck fan 88 said I'm going with
the room on this one I really want to
hear a song about Tommy telling Lisa why
she's tearing him apart give some black
box snarky people in LA like two years
you'll get that and then finally
chainsaw cat 19 said killing of a sacred
deer would be the best stage musical I
never got a musical but let's make it
happen get help yeah Wow
killing of a sacred arrow music I don't
want to see it just Tommy Wiseau if you
want the room the musical to get made
give me a call wait do not never call
myself okay it's time for the speed
round here's how it works there are four
speed round questions the first person
to get four correct answers moves on and
now these questions these answers will
be decided by the rounds we decided by
myself lon and Danielle Radford's very
own opinion of the battle I get to have
opinions heck yeah and again the first
person to speak will get to talk first I
have a question I've been here a while
am i competing I I'm assuming they've
moved on or yes they move okay I just
want to make sure I'm not going to yell
so it's Danvers Erica when I ask the
question they the first person to speak
will get to give their opening thoughts
first and they get 20 seconds 20 seconds
and then 10 second rebuttal 10 second
rebuttal all right
fighters are you ready oh yeah as ready
as we can be what will be the bigger
summer sequel Incredibles 2 or Jurassic
world incredible - Jurassic world -
alright
we heard Erica first with Incredibles -
the clock will begin whenever you speak
I said it before and I said it again an
Incredibles has a lot to say right now
when the rise of superhero culture it's
gonna be a classic it I mean just from
the trailers alone
the writing is great the acting is great
it looks even better than the first one
I I really honestly in and it's gonna
get it's gonna get an Oscar we know we
know that it's gonna get an Oscar
unfortunately none of those quality
those relate to quality the question is
what it's going to do the bigger one and
unfortunately for all of us it's going
to be Jurassic world - Jurassic world's
one of the top five money makers of all
time this is going to be a massive
sequel there's still questions about
whether Incredibles has the box office
pull that the original had I think the
Jurassic world is gonna make more money
it's gonna be bigger people more people
are gonna go see it and right now the
summer is a bit light on a
child-friendly fare and I think that the
Incredibles is gonna be pulling that
box-office money and I think it's gonna
have longer legs overall because
everybody's gonna go see traffic park
first week and then not have good luck
but the summer is incredibly having on
superhero fair and credible is gonna be
one of three or four superhero movies
opening the summer there is only one
movie where you can see dinosaurs that's
gonna be drastic world - it's not up to
me but it's gonna make way more money
time alright there's no Danielle oh yeah
both really compelling arguments but I
have to say that Erika won me over with
her argument about there not being a lot
for like
family-friendly movies and movies take
kids to this summer so I'm gonna go with
Erica that's 104 Erica I thought that
Eric had a great point with that but I
thought Dan rebutted it nicely and he
painted the stronger case for Jurassic
world too so I'm going for Dan so lon
it's up to you Wow both both good
arguments but yeah I thought Erica's
argument about the there's not a lot of
kid-friendly fair hit home and I didn't
think that I didn't hear a great
response to that one I mean yeah it's
Super Heroes vs dinosaurs but I think
people have sort of an infinite capacity
for superheroes so I'm going with Erica
all right Erica takes the point it is
three one Erica
dan needs this to continue the what was
the fact on is I mean like a prehistoric
creature can we go back to the first
question so it's it's three one Erica
Dan needs this to continue the game
Erica continues what's that I mean all
of them to continue the game this is
true
dan is facing sanity all right Erica you
take any of these next questions and you
went for key speed around question
number two Deadpool's new team features
Rob Delaney as a powerless superhero dad
what movie dad without powers should
join The Avengers just like crude into
The Avengers
Liam Neeson in taken okay
I'm going with John Lithgow from Harry
and the Hendersons
okay my child
Liam Neeson's particular set of skills
versus John Lithgow from Harry and the
Hendersons the old Sasquatch movie
alright
you spoke first Erica so twenty seconds
begins when you speak Liam Neeson has a
particular set of skills I think that he
would really add a lot to the Avengers
we need to see we've been trying to get
diversity at all of it and we actually
don't have one for age right now Liam
Neeson set of skills make him like the
12th most awesome Avenger however John
Lithgow has aged yes he has experience
he's dealt with creatures before and
he's transfixing who doesn't love John
Lithgow he's everybody loves him he can
cozy up to the villains he can be a
double agent he's one of the most
lovable guys in the world you can assert
him into any situation and he will adapt
because he's John Lithgow we're gonna
get some dead Avengers in this next one
we need somebody who's willing to kill
people on the other side that person is
Liam Neeson he will take no prisoners if
John Lithgow can went over a sasquatch
he can win over Thanos it's not our
moment to and John Lithgow can diffuse
the situation through sheer charisma
time
[Applause]
it's an eighties movie about a sasquatch
that with a family mean to ya alright so
man what uh dance row down at the end of
the day he was you painted him as
lovable Dan but then you also gave him
practical skills he cajoled a sasquatch
he was able to make nice with a
sasquatch that that power translates dan
took this one for me let's go to
Danielle yeah I have to get this one to
Dan I was really in on that liam neeson
age argument but Dan is correct and that
both of them would be able to put it
down for the seminarians I don't know
that's a big word but then Dan did get
me with we do need someone who's going
to be able to sue the Hulk and if
there's anyone who's gonna be able to
tell him you know boom Dan takes that
point it is three two three two it's
still sudden-death here Erica takes this
she takes the game here's question
number three of the speed round we're
getting grown-up actors to play all the
kids in the next int but if you were
also age what actor if you were also
aged what actor should join the sequel
as old man penny wise
who is it in the original one or in the
first one in the first one
skarsgård bill bill scar scar
which I think creepy old dudes couple
right here Christopher Walken Dan Dick
Van Dyke Wow 90 something very exciting
choices all right Erica you spoke first
whenever you're ready twenty seconds
whenever you speak twenty seconds begins
everybody here in this studio went oh
because everybody wants to see
Christopher Walken do penny wise he's
when you think of like quirky odd a
little creepy actors you think of
Christopher Walken and it's been that
way since Annie Hall that's it I agree
Christopher Walken this creepy and
off-putting he's been doing that bit for
forty years we've seen him do it so many
more times what would be more terrifying
than a jagged toothed man-eating Dick
Van Dyke
he's like America's grandpa and now he's
going to climb out of the sewers and
devour you whole
what is more unnerving than America's
grandfather eating the grandchildren of
America he just doesn't have it in him I
don't think he actually is physically
capable of making a creepy face
honestly I Dick Van Dyke is just and
sell it for me I think he's a hundred
percent capable of it he is a
classically trained actor he's been
doing musicals and stuff and again
Walken is the easy choice there's
nothing surprising there's nothing
inventive he's been doing that he did
and Sleepy Hollow he's basically penny
wise with the teeth and everything
there's nothing fun about time Wow
alright let's go to long I mean I
thought they were both interesting picks
I was one of the people going when I
heard Chris we're walking cuz it is an
interest
choice but Dan really won me over with
the walkins the sort of more obvious
choice but dick Nick would be really
unsettling because of how well we know
him culturally I'm giving this one a Dan
Danielle uh yeah I do have to agree I'm
also slightly disappointed that there
was no room in the argument to talk
about Christopher Walken being able to
do that tap dance
tap dancing it but yeah I do have to
agree that Dan's argument was stronger
when it talked about America's grandpa
that really hit me yeah coming out of
the sewer like that Dan you take the
point we are logged up at three three
ladies and gentleman this is a great
moment at sports the correct answer was
Clint Howard by the way okay
[Applause]
okay we're tied up at 3 3 this is for
all of the marbles and by all the
marbles I mean today's victory here it
is Edgar Ramirez has joined the rocks
upcoming film the Jungle Cruise what's
the best movie that's set in the jungle
predator best movie set in the jungle
five four African Queen African Queen
okay we have the predator versus the
African Queen Dan you spoke first 20
seconds begin when you speak predators
not just set in the jungle the monster
is the jungle and that's what makes that
movie so great the jungles not just a
setting it is a character with the
predator being everywhere I love the
oppressiveness you can feel the heat you
can feel the the swampy rainforest in
this and the fact that you can't breathe
you're being stalked
it's not just a setting it's a part of
the movie and that's why when I think of
jungle movie I think of predator well
the jungle couldn't have been too
quintessential to predator because they
set a bunch of them elsewhere but with
African Queen is very much part of the
jungle that it's them it's man versus
nature
it's a Katharine Hepburn and Humphrey
Bogart at the peak of what made them
them in in the classic Hollywood era
they set printer 2 in the city and it
didn't work that proves how important
the jungle is and the African Queen it's
mostly set on a river it's barely even
in the jungle again the predator
completely jungles set so claustrophobic
great use of setting an atmosphere when
best action movies
okay the river is in the jungle it's not
in the trees Dan but I I mean I feel
like just one one of those is the
classic time all right
Wow yeah Dan's opening salvo was so
strong and then his rebuttal sent you
back on your heels trying to defend it
and I give the point to Dan Danielle I
have to agree as much as African Queen
is a classic I do feel like Dan came
with some stronger points I'm going for
predator dan Moreau comes from behind
[Applause]
nicely done dan dan please
and plug some stuff or just you know
talk some junk whatever you'll please
check out our women in film fundraiser
everyone has been incredible we keep
setting stretch goals and stretch goals
and stretch goals and we are close to
the 30 thousand which is insane we said
with a ten thousand dollar goal and
we're close to thirty thousand dollars
which will unlock the belt in the movie
fight that's happening in our benefit
two weeks from today
Wow please go check out our women in
film event donate or spread the word if
you can we're so grateful to everyone
that's donated so far it's going so
amazing and it's such an amazing cause
so please go check that out
hell yeah big cosign for me on that
background to the birthday boy Ken naps
are much fun yeah hey man if you want to
follow my adventures I always love come
back to this family here but I got the
knapsack files podcast for center
podcast white tuck Star Wars with Joseph
scrim show Jennifer Lando and I got a
big live Schmoe town it's live meaning
in a theater with people June 2nd the El
Portal Theatre knows Halloween get
tickets and I got a big Star Wars trivia
battle against scrimshaw and also Alex
Damon of Star Wars explain and guys I
actually had done a little thing on my
channel where I had my birthday a little
wish list and anything I received I'm
gonna be donating a dollar amount to
your guys as women and film in the name
of some of my supporters and fans too
I'm back from Vegas early to attend it
so can't wait
thank you Ken Knapp saw Erica ECU came
in and brought it you brought it
speed round has been many a fighters on
doing it but you are incredible please
go ahead love some stuff that was really
fun
um so I am on Twitter at Eric Ishi I
just do a ton of stuff on the internet
you can catch me on to Tuesday's on on
Fridays on geek and sundry's twitch
channel on my own twitch channel as well
twitch.tv slash Erica Ishay and yeah I
will be part of the the screen junkies
movie or movie fights for the film is so
spectacular and all of you thanks to all
of you for donating enough to unlock the
anime tier which I will also be debating
in oh hell yeah
well played thank you so much laud
Harris nicely done on the facts saying
what not but go ahead and plug something
long why also shout out to the women in
film event can't wait for that looking
forward to it also I did want to mention
I write a newsletter I don't forget to
do this about streaming shows like what
the best stuff to watch is streaming
online you can go to inside.com /
dreaming to sign up for insight
streaming streaming needs lon Harris
Daniel Radford thank you for everything
thank you as per usual please follow me
on instagram trying to get that awesome
fat lady merch help me help me help me
and then you don't have to watch me wear
the same five dresses over and over says
just Danielle underscore Bradford I do
wanted we got in a last minute think
meme um bc us underscore i'm batman who
did infinity for the most ambitious
crossover ever and he photoshop her they
photoshopped a giant picture thank me
Thank You Danielle for holding it down
and I want to thank you for watching
movie fights please donate to our women
in film as everyone said we are blown
away by the amount raised and thanks
again for watching I'm Hal right neck
hit me up on Twitter at Hal Rudnick and
thanks for watching see you next time
bye bye